good morning john it is friday good
morning hank that was very good i'm
about to follow up i could do this
use your core
so john you uh have been talking to me
about crown hill cemetery for a long
time highest point in indianapolis
america's greatest cemetery the most
vice presidents per square mile anywhere
in the u.s true long as you count dead
ones so here's what we decided to do i
was like let's go epitaph hunting yeah
and then we will reconvene and share the
best epidemic if you have the money to
spare a few extra words onto your
tombstone i think it adds a lot yeah
even just one banana i want to start
with this guy here hank stan mollis he
died in 2012 and his uh tombstone is a
tennis net and it says game set match
because that's when it's over that's
what that's when it's all over see a
tennis player he was not only a tenant
he was a professional tennis player he
owned the magnet company that designed
magnets for the apollo mission that were
instrumental magnets to
the uh
apollo mission mooning oh to a to a moon
arrival to america's mooning yes sick
i'm sure you recalled neil armstrong's
first words upon landing on the moon
i am mooning let us moon
[Laughter]
we did it buzz we're mooning what is
that is that your are you mooning yeah
he's moaning now what is your
understanding of the verb to moon walk
upon the moon oh okay this one was weird
laughter is the best medicine
why are you on this planet
i mean it's very funny and it's like i
don't know man great question i found a
similarly inscrutable one the sober one
is currently on tour you will always
remain in our hearts forever so the
first one is currently the first part
sounds like on artificial intelligence
is right
john this one on the back in quotation
marks just says
i'm all right i'm all right i'm all
right while we're talking about ones
that are lovely he filled his niche and
accomplished his task he left the world
better than he found it that's nice i
think it's lovely we've talked about
good ones i think we should talk about
some bad ones beginning with this guy
ebenezer dumont my criticism is that
he's obviously a very accomplished
person he has listed way too many
accomplishments the font gets too small
and so you end up you can't even read
all the things that that he did you've
got to pick a couple things like
benjamin harrison who was president of
the united states picked a couple of
things it says lawyer and publicist
which it turns out
meant something different then yeah it
seems like a weird thing to pick out
like i was a lawyer and also i helped
people get into us weekly
back then it meant like uh
a person concerned with or expert in
right issues of the public ah i am very
fond of the idea that even the things we
etch in stone are not necessarily
absolutely
i like to this one to live in the hearts
of others is not to die
these days mausoleums cost like what
houses they don't do them anymore very
rarely the last one was the bane one oh
my god the bane one can we talk about it
it's on the hill where the fancy people
are buried it's a very normal looking
mausoleum it's got a nice little wall
it's got a walkway a lot of space a lot
of space it's open it's very
neoclassical and i've always just walked
past it and thought like that's a
mausoleum hank green ever curious walks
up to the edge of the mausoleum and what
is inside is
truly astonishing i'm sorry that i
couldn't get better footage of it than
this i and more power to him like yeah
yeah i mean it's such an odd place
because of course it is very somber yeah
and there is a lot of sadness there but
there is also room for that thank you
for taking me there thank you for
showing me around you're becoming a
legitimate tour guide of crown hill well
now that'll be your job eventually oh
gosh someday john i'll see you now bye